we have been on really good terms for a
while Taylor Swift and Katy Perry's
reunion has apparently been a long time
coming
[Music]
after a year's long feud between the pop
stars the two seemingly put their
differences aside to work together on
Taylor's new you need to calm down video
[Music]
now Taylor confirms the beef is indeed
squashed here's what she told the BBC
radio 1 breakfast show so the first time
we saw each other was at this party and
when we thought each other it was very
clear to both of us everything was
different that we had grown up that we
had grown past allowing ourselves to
sort of be sated against each other and
so both of us have been in a really good
place for a while but I don't think
either of us really knew if we were ever
gonna talk about it publicly and she
explained how Katy's cameo in the video
came to be when I thought of this
concept of a video and I wrote the
treatment I thought of this idea and I
thought you know I'm just gonna ask her
if she'd be interested in this but I
would be totally fine if she but she'd
rather to keep it private and keep it
between us but I sent it to her and you
know she was like I she was like I would
love for us to be a symbol of redemption
and forgiveness
oh and Taylor also explained the
symbolic meaning behind their burger and
french fry ensembles wore that Jeremy's
got burgers to the Met Gala afterparty
and I was thinking you know we're gonna
have this moment in the video if it's to
like us wearing normal clothes and
hugging it won't really fit into this
video because this video is very wacky
it's very looks surreal so I was like
can we do burgers fries I was like I'm
full for like two people who belong
together and he thought it was really
funny and but we did it also burger
starts with a B french fries with two
F's put it together and you've got BFF
after the video dropped Katie shared
this shot on Instagram with the caption
this meal is beef free and a source told
ET that Katie was extra down to do the
video because of its strong Pro LGBTQ
rights messaging and what better way to
put her in Taylor's issues behind them
than working towards a good cause in
fact at the end of the video Taylor
actually encourages her fans to sign her
petition for Senate support of the
Equality Act
[Music]
Kady teased that there was no bad blood
between them last week sharing this pic
of chocolate-chip cookies with the words
peace at last written on the plate in
red frosting
the pop star captioned the shot quote
feels good taylor swift and geo tagged
the location on her post as let's be
friends I'm so excited
Taylor replied in the comment section
with a ton of heart emojis and of course
now that they have shared the screen and
downed peace cookies fans want a collab
and they might just be in luck you guys
check out what Katie told et in March
about the possibility of a Taylor Katy
track we're so excited to get new music
from you but here's the thing Taylor
Swift was just on his carpet before you
what about the rumors that Katy Perry
and Taylor Swift could make music
together I mean I'm making music with
Zedd I'm open open open open where do we
sign the petition I am so down for this
of course we'll be here to keep you up
to date on this budding friendship so
make sure to keep it locked right here
on ET until next time I'm Hallie Stevens
bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]